[موسيقى]
اهلا بكل متابعي صباح العربيه
ضيفتي في رصيدها اكثر من 70 فيلما
سينمائيا ولا يوجد هناك اي دور تمثيلي
والا ادعم اما عن اطلالاتها فهي بكل تاكيد
تتحدى الزمن ومثل ما يقول كاظم الساهر كل
ما تكبر تحلى النجمه ليلى علوي
نورتي نورتي انت اللي منور دايما وعلى
فكره بالحقيقه هي كلش احلى الله الله
يخليك ليلتي متواجده في لوس انجلس اليوم
تم تكريمك في مهرجان هوليود للافلام
العربيه بجائزه عزيزه امير الحمد لله
خبرينا عن شلون كان التكريم شلون كان ايضا
ردود الفعل الناس اللي كانوا موجودين في
المهرجان اولا انا بشكر المهرجان جدا
المهرجان ده ليه تاني سنه بس
عاملين لاداره المهرجان وبتنظيمه مجتهدين
جدا كلهم شباب كلهم مصريين كلهم حابين
السينما ودارسين سينما جائزه امير طبعا
يعني عزيزه على قلبي جدا جدا جدا وبشكر
المهرجان عليها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شلون تقيمين وضع السينما والدراما بمصر
بالفتره الاخيره في تطور الحمد لله
والانتاج الدراما السنه دي كان هايل انا
اتفرجت على مسلسلات في رمضان لقيت ان في
اختيارات كتيره للجمهور يعني انت مثلا
اللي عايز كومنت هيلاقي اللي عايز دراما
هيلاقي قضيه هيلاقي اللي عايز رومانسيتك
هيلاقي اللي عايز اكشن
فانا شايفه انها من السنوات اللي كانت
ناجحه جدا للدراما المصريه والعربيه ايضا
يعني ما معقوله انه انت تكونين موجوده
وياي بلقاء وما استغل الفرصه واسالك على
التاريخ السري لكوثر وين صار هذا وين راح
نشوفها
هو التصوير الفيلم تتاخر شويتين
وهو جاهز للعرض ولكن للاسف مع طاقاتش ان
هو هينزل
بالسنمات
ولسه اعتقد هينزل منصات فقط وفي موعد محدد
لهذا الموضوع
يعني تاكيد اقدر اقوله لكن هو فيلم مع
المخرج محمد امين والسي الجميل وزينه
فيلم مختلف
ابدا بس اكو شيء بداخل ليله تحب تقدم عمل
ميوزك
خبرينا شنو هذا
الموضوع بس اصلا اصلا وانا طفله انا بشتغل
من هون الطفله برامج الاطفال في برامج
الاطفال كنا بنغني وبنرقص ونعمل مشاهد
تمثيليه فده موجود
جوايا انا بعشق المزيكا المزيكا بيتحرك
مشاعري واحساسي وبتغير مودي تديني طاقه
ايجابيه جدا
بما نجد تحبين الميوزك شو الاغاني بتسمع
هي عاده يعني بحياتك اليوميه الصبح الظهر
بالليل بحب اسمع ميوزك مثلا بس يعني اغاني
قديمه بس يكون التوزيع بتاعها
عندي واحده صاحبتي عامله لي موت جود
مورنينج
ولذيذ وفرش
بس انا بحب الجاس من الحاجات
وان شاء الله مره هنقعد نسمع مع بعض
بحب الاغاني القديمه طبعا لام كلثوم وعبد
الحليم وفريد وبحب اغاني كتير جدا من
الفنانين شباب
بسمع شيرين بسمه عمرو دياب طبعا
بسمع يعني كله يعني بسمع يعني مش عايز
اقول اسماء عشان اكيد مش هفتكر كله بس انا
لا اللحن الحلو والكلمات الحلوه بتاثر فيا
وبتحركني وبتغير مودي
بسمع كتير قوي تامر حسني بموت في الاغنيه
بتاعته
اللي هو انا هعيش لوحدي واسمع نفسي
طبعا اكيد بما انه ذكرنا الفنانه الرائعه
شيرين من عشاقها جدا كلنا من عشاقة اليوم
ما شفت الها انه هي فعلا الها عوده كبيره
وموجوده على المسرح وهذا المكان اللي يلوق
لها تاكيد الله يوفق ذكرت وانت معروف عنك
انه انت انسانه محبه وجدا عاطفيا وذكرت
باللقاء انه انت كنت من الناس يلي
موجوده بجانبها بالاوقات الصعبه بطريقه ما
فشو تحبين تقولين لشيرين اقول لها ان انا
واحده من معجبينك يا شيرين انت الفنانه
عظيمه وصوت مميز جدا
وتاريخي الكبير وعمره ما حيتاثر باي حاجه
فرحانه ان انت موجوده على المسرح وبنشاطك
جدا جدا ومستنيين منك كل ما هو جديد ورائع
شلون نقول بالمصري احنا بالعراق نتمشى
شلون يقولون بالمصري يلا خلينا نتمشى
بما انه احنا متواجدين في هوليود اكيد
لازم اسالك على الممثلين
هوليود الي انت تحبيهم يعني هم كثير هم
كثير قوي قوي قوي يعني طبعا الممثله
المفضله عندي طبعا ميرفت يعني اكتر واحده
بحس انها لا لا يعني مثلا هقول لك حاجه
كان في اجازه نص السنه وكان في افلام
وعايزه اخد الاولاد ويروح السينما وكده
فكان في فيلمين فيلم اطفال مصري اطفالي
حلو قوي قوي ونجاح قوي قوي
وكان في ماما ميع فرحنا اولاد انا طبعا
يعني عايزه الموسيقى بتجنن
لا والطاقه لكل اللي في الفيلم عامله ازاي
فارس بحبها قوي طبعا برضه يعني متاثره بها
ديمومور يعني لا كثير اتوقع بحسب راي
المتواضع انه انت تاريخك بالوطن العربي
مثل مير ستريب مثل
المستقبليه شنو القادم
ان شاء الله بحضر فيلمي
ونازله على تصوير فيلم اسمه عائله شاذلي
اللي ايتن امين هي مخرجه مميزه جدا
والسيناريو وجميل ومختلف ان شاء الله يا
رب نتوفق فيه
[موسيقى]
ليلى المحبين كثار وانا استمتعت جدا بهذا
اللقاء ويا ريت لو كان اطول بكل صراحه ان
شاء الله نعمل حوار تاني باذن الله شنو
حابه تقولي لي كل المحبين والمتابعين عبر
شاشه العربيه اقول لهم انا بحب جمهوري
وبشكر جمهوري جدا جدا جدا لان بجد هم
بيدوني طاقه وتشجيع من اول يوم بداتي في
حياتي مرت عليا اجيال سعيده بيها
ويا رب دائما ابقى عند حسن ظنكم وتشوفوا
معايا كل ما هو جديد وممتع وبهذا شكرا على
حسن المتابعه وعوده مع الزملاء في
الاستوديو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات